what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to kevin
samuels stella lost her group and now
wants a high value man
i'm excited i want to know how stella
lost her groove
and if she's gonna find a high value man
i have a feeling i know where this is
going
before i start do not forget to like
comment and subscribe
um i'm trying to hit 20 000 subscribers
so if you got a second
hit that subscribe button help a girl
out
and let me know in the comments what you
think is the most
important quality that women should look
for in dating and men let me know for
both
carefully what do you want to know
well who are you all these girls are
flirting with him
i don't care what anyone says flirting
like just look at her eyes
well i am on the west coast so i've been
watching for a little while i noticed
everybody is
kind of midwest and in atlanta so i am
in
so they're all over the applications of
the world
are countrywide yeah i'm in socal i'm in
cali
how old are you i am 27.
hi so give me the tray of download
well i am a realtor here in socal
i am single and i have no kids okay and
i guess you could say i'm an alpha
female
and um
i don't know based on kind of what
everybody else has been talking about
i'm five eight
um i'm 155 pounds um my dress size is
eight
working on getting back to a six um
i work out three i work out three times
a week
would you like to be married yes how
long how long was your longest
relationship
um my last relationship real
relationship is four years
longest your longest four years okay how
long ago was that
three years ago so you're 27
and your last lecture was three years
ago it was four years so you were there
personally 20 years old
actually i'm older than that i was
playing with you
i just gave you the 27 number because
everybody always says they think i'm 27.
why lady what are you doing
don't give me that don't give me that
look
i've actually thought she looked older
than 27.
i'm doing business here so can we get to
the truth oh like don't give me that
lick no i'm 36.
oh damn i would have thought she was 30.
let's just stick to the truth
um your last relationship was three
years ago
uh three to four years ago yes and it
lasted four years
yes um who ended it
i did uh any particular reason
lots of reasons he was younger than me
i'm much
younger four years younger i started
dating him when i was 30. so he was four
years younger than me when i was 30.
okay so you know i learned him
i'm sorry so you out earned him yes
all right so uh if you were married do
you want to have children
yes how many kids i can at least two
uh these two and after you're uh
pregnant would you like to have the work
to pay significant bills
yes i'm going to work okay
um if i asked your ex-boyfriend how he
experienced you what
his word would be trey is what
controlling
she gives that vibe she gives very
masculine energy
and i'm curious to see i'm sure he's
going to get into it what he would
recommend for women
that are just naturally like more
masculine because you can't ask someone
to change their entire personality
and not care about work you know if
that's something she's really passionate
about
demanding i get i get the word demanding
a lot
um and you want to what kind of marriage
do you have
um i want a partnership um
no i mean as far as you know i want to
laugh a lot i like i just want to be
happy i want to be happy
i want to laugh a lot um i don't take
myself seriously i don't take life
seriously
i want to i want to be able to be open
like i don't want lies i don't want
secrets i want us to
be able to talk to each other about
anything are you are you a christian
i'm not religious okay so um
man just come down like two basic forms
either traditional marriage whether
they're gender roles
or some sort of partnership
okay what do you want a partnership
and do you mind if your uh
spouse earns less than you no i don't
mind
okay this woman's actually a lot more
reasonable than the women i've seen on
her show
if it was me then i would
do you think she'd be happy in a beta
male relationship
um do you own your home
no how much does it mean
here's a real question what's how much
does a man need to make
annually before you consider him
seriously
how much does he need to make where i
consider him seriously
yeah before you consider your
seriousness
at the bare minimum being in in cali
bare minimum would be a hundred thousand
and that's bare minimum oh no
you were part of california i'm in san
diego
she's going to be single forever right
that's what he's going to say
no what percentage of men earn over a
hundred thousand dollars a year
ten percent you say what percentage what
percentage of men earn more than six
figures over one hundred thousand
dollars a year
any race huh any race
yeah any race 10 to 15
10 10 so
you automatically eliminated 9 out of 10
men
at age 36 but i also say that i'm okay
that he makes less
i said how much would he need to make
minimum you said six
figures yeah and you also said are you
okay if he makes less and i said i'm
going to take her
less than you oh
i said oh i'm sorry i missed i
misunderstood that
how much money would he need to make
annually before you would
seriously consider him poor marriage
okay i would say that i would say 70 and
up
i'll be honest because i mean i i do i
do
i do well too so that doesn't matter
i i know it doesn't i'll be i gotta be
honest we started off
wrong would you lying to me all right
that's
that's just not okay i was messing with
you
i'm a jokester okay she does not seem
funny
she's pretty though she does not look 37
i thought she was 30.
we all know each other and that's all
right that is the thing i'll be honest
and be
honest it's just it's off-putting so
uh but then you say you're an alpha
female under control freak and
um i don't
the kind of men that you are probably
except i don't really
deal in like beta males i do
attract a lot of beta males which is
crazy but i don't but i don't deal with
those
i don't i don't i really i would prefer
an album i would prefer an alpha male
but i
you know i don't i don't attract them
you know i feel like
i feel like i'm kind of demanding and
controlling by default
because i do attract betas listen
lady yeah listen you're on a show i feel
like if i ran into the right alpha
i would i would fall in that to i would
fall in that submissive role because i
can be that
but i can't i can't let the blind lead
the blind like you
like you have to be that leader men men
tend not to be a leader
um you attract betas because
you're dominating a controller you can
attract alphas they just won't
they will not keep you they won't accept
you they don't
want you they don't need your money
and alpha alpha males high-value men
productive competitive successful men
make enough money to where they don't
have to deal with it
so this thing about i could be feminine
you either are or you are not it's not
it's what you turn on and off
that's what i'm curious because some
girls it's literally just their
personality
so what do you do if that's your
personality it's not a value judgment
but i don't really deal with beta males
and 50 50 stuff
that's just not the platform i'm in
um because that's not that's not a
natural role for women
the alpha energy the controlling energy
i mean yeah women need to be able to
take care of themselves in a modern
scenario
but you don't have to be a control freak
and if you were involved how long
four years four years before the
guy that was four years younger than you
yes
yes yeah wrong platform you you you
that's some stella got a groove back
kind of [ __ ] going on
see he doesn't seem to think it can work
at
all with men that make less
is it that's the vibe i'm getting let me
know in the comments if
i'm right or i'm wrong
so i've been around
i've been around alpha males and when
somebody
is is strong and they take the lead it's
it's natural for me to
take that back seat when that person is
capable of doing that
what you seem to keep missing is like
like an alpha male has to prove
something to you
no not proof that's just who they are
listen no they're not
see alpha males attract
feminine women and what you're saying is
if i would consider being feminine if
an alpha male steps up and leads and
does something to put me in my family
he's gone off by this business with this
woman
alpha males aren't in the business of
proving to you you must prove to us
when i go sit and negotiate with you
we'll just leave you with the 24
with the four year younger boy that's
what a lot of
you aggressive women don't seem to get
nobody's going to prove anything to you
man
there are more females on the planet
than men
and at 36 years old talking about you on
the man making six figures
um which is really what you want
i don't believe for one minute you'd
accept the man making seventy thousand
dollars in southern california
that's 35 000 in atlanta i don't believe
that for one bid
i i don't need it i i take care of
myself
[Laughter]
i mean it would be nice but you know
i i don't need it you know
but i mean you know i i hear you talk a
lot about that but
one thing i i do want to say is the one
thing i feel
kind of that you're missing is that
you're not a woman and you're not out
here
dating these men it's like there's young
men you know there's
men in the middle and there's older men
and
you're not out here dating them like i'm
actually out here
going on dates with all types and the
older ones doesn't
don't automatically make them mature and
the young ones don't automatically make
them
dang so she ah you don't attack a guy on
his platform when he's trying to help
you that's just not
good
i just let you say all that because i'm
arrogant of you
that's arrogant because you don't know
me you don't know my background
i'm 51 years old i've been over three
church singles ministries
and i talked to you don't know my
background
see the thing is many women think just
like yourself think you got it all
figured out and people need to get up to
your level
you're 15 years younger than me you
think you're gonna put me up on game
i'm not saying that i'm saying i'm not
missing anything
of course i don't date me that's all i
said and the thing
is the dating men is not the point you
guys can women control access to sex
men control access to relationships and
the problem is women cannot get
relationships today because you suck at
them
modern women suck at keeping
relationships damn
keep men who are ranked higher value
period point blank end of sentence
but would you agree that this generation
of like this dating pool
sucks as a whole both sides no
you ladies do
that's not true okay i'm just i'd like
to put a caveat
that men are not as masculine as they
used to be
ladies the problem
objectively is with women because men
have not
changed the expectations for men are
still to be the same
protector provider prophet priests we're
still expected to do things that any man
of any generation has done
if you've watched my show over six
months the thing that's different
is women have less skills less feminine
energy
lessening this and they're demanding
more i've had women on this show tonight
who don't even have cookbooks
can't cook i have both of those
i feel attacked i can't cook
i'm sorry i can't
i do but it's not a passion of mine
but the thing is women previous
generations two three four years back
they prided themselves on the things
that many women today simply cannot do
but you have to understand that it's
this is also modern day where you can
get like a meal subscription
or there's a lot more technology when it
comes to cooking where you don't have to
make [ __ ] from like scratch anymore
you know i'm not saying like some guys
want their girl to cook all the time
but it's 20 20 you don't have to
they didn't need to be alpha realtors
and make money they were proud of being
mothers so sorry
you the reason the dating pool sucks
the reason chivalry is dead is because
modern women killed it
yeah i agree but i agree with that and i
cook very well and i do have cookbooks
okay they start to look sad when they
start to like really try to
appeal their like show kevin that
they're valuable
you cannot get the kind of man that you
can respect
let's just put it on the wood you cannot
no it's not slim pickings it's in the
mirror
oh it's not slim picking damn i know i
have some self work to do and i and i
work on that daily
okay the worst name of your theories oh
i do i will say that you you said a word
are you writing me you don't have a
therapist
you said you said i don't have it there
exactly so you're in charge i don't have
a therapist
do i need money well let's look
let's arguably look business person
let's look at the outcomes is what
you're doing working
are you qualified to fix you
yes really show me an attorney who
represents himself and i'll show you an
attorney who has a fool for a client
damn okay damn can i tell you why ma'am
you're not qualified to be your own
therapist
but if i know but if i this is the
problem she's arrogant
she's so arrogant you know what my
issues are am i not
qualified to work on my own issues if i
know what they are all right you're
right let me show you how let me show
you how
to do this guys when you deal with women
sign language shaming themselves guilt
and the need to be right that's what you
do with them you're right
you're right i'm not trying to be right
kevin of course but you're right anyway
i'm not trying to be right but you are
i'm not trying to be right i swear i'm
not yeah but see but you're the best
person to be your own therapist because
you know your own issues
and you know how to address them you're
right so what do you see my issues being
beside even though you use the word
aggressive
i don't like the word aggressive i don't
care if you like it
okay lady let him talk you're on his
platform
oh my goodness i don't know if you like
it or not you don't talk to me
i'm saying here's one issue right here
you're over talking to me i i apologize
that's one issue right there that's a
bad habit is starting to assert
your issue your instinct is to pull out
your dick
put your dick up
and the only reason you've been able to
get away with it as long as you have is
cause you're cuter than most
if you're really just average or
unattractive you got this [ __ ] checked a
long time ago
damn damn
oh man that's so true because okay
i have friends that are like prettier
than me and the stuff i see them
get away with
or the way that certain guys will like
talk to them or like
they'll get out of stuff i'm like
it's hard i'm i'm not trying to put
myself down in any way but i know where
i fall
i'm not fascinated i'm dealing with
beautiful women all the time
they do it attractive women all the time
not special to me and the problem is you
have you say yourself as a control freak
an alpha female what men say oh
i cannot wait to find me a controlled
freaking alpha female that's what i
really [ __ ] want
you asked me you asked me what the
feedback was that's not what
i said but i say what men want those who
what what
what caliber or kind of man do you hear
saying you know what
i just really want a domineering
business i just want a ball breaker
can't wait to find a control freak who
says that
can i answer that sure of course
okay course obviously not in so many
words right
but i feel like some men actually do
would like a stronger woman that they
can count on to step up to handle things
they
some men don't always want some soft
damsel in the stress like oh well my
husband's not here my husband is i don't
know what to do
i can't think for myself my husband my
husband so
i feel like some men actually want a
woman who agrees with me
and there's something again like you
said you don't date
uh men you don't know men
i don't know many men who want what
you're talking about
men who don't you feel like there are
some and where are these men
at who are they
tell me where they are in your life tell
me where you've gone to get this
information
okay it's interesting i know because
my dad is like technically one of the
high value man i mean i don't
they have so many different definitions
so it all depends on your definition but
like
income alone it puts him in like the top
you know
ten five probably like one or two
percent i don't know it doesn't matter
high percentage and i asked him because
my mom worked our entire life
we had nannies and i asked him if he'd
like prefer that she stayed home
and he surprisingly told me that he
would have
even though she like did really well for
their company and stuff
and that was and yeah it i was
sorry i think can't talk today but i was
surprised because
i like wasn't expecting that at all so
he definitely has a point on them
how many a few few
few is what four a few is four
i mean i didn't put a number on it but
if you let's put a number on it cuz it
matters
oh i didn't think about the actual
number well
well you said i feel their men like this
how many
what percentage of men do you think are
like that
a percentage of men that are like that
it was important enough for you to make
it a position in the conversation
so i need to know what percentage of men
fall into this category to see how
important the point you're trying to
make
is i don't know an exact number but
i'm going to be honest and probably say
maybe it's the majority is probably not
that high me it's probably not the
majority i would say
[Music]
damn realtor you have to give me a
number just ballpark it
10 10 negligible
huh damn negligible 10
so that means 90 of men don't want what
you're talking about
okay so why are we talking about the ten
percent
instead of the 90 she would get a lot
more help if she stopped arguing with
him about the little details
and just said like my dad always taught
me to focus on the solution instead of
the problem
so like what solutions would help her
and let me know in the comments what
solutions would help her
get married and i know at the manosphere
is
known you guys all comment it's over
after 35
it's over for women like this like that
like that and
you know maybe it's over for a lot of
people but i have seen women
get married later in life i have seen
women grow and change
um i'm not an expert in it by any means
but the whole message that
like women are not capable of redemption
and bettering themselves
personally just doesn't sit right with
me
but yeah let me know in the comments
what you think would help her
i'll tell you why because you don't know
how to deal with the 90s
you don't know what they want and even
if you did
are you prepared or qualified to give it
to you
yes tell me the last relationship where
you've been submissive
the last relationship i've been
submissive
start to finish it was a very long time
ago
okay what was it like long time ago
okay i don't know you when was it
probably
high school okay who was he
my boyfriend in five years and how were
you when you started seeing it
how was i how old were you uh 17.
so last time you acted like a feminine
woman was 22.
oh no i act like a family woman all the
time
you asked me about that no no no no
listen i said when's the last
relationship you were submissive
see a feminine woman is submissive
you can't rewrite femininity to fit your
definition
so a feminine woman can't be alpha no
no no is that your opinion no
feminine femininity is not alpha it's
soft
and there is no such thing as an alpha
woman that's another thing you women
it's just that if you try to say
amazonian that's another thing you
you might need to put your dicks up
you're not an alpha
the only reason you can do the [ __ ] you
do is cause mankind civilize the world
in general
you are a female
that i am and the more you start acting
in line with your
nature the happier you would be and i do
so where did it turn off oh my gosh lady
listen to him ask him about solutions
oh my goodness okay if you acted okay if
you acted
you'd be with an older man you'd be with
a man to where he was in charge and you
were following
but you do understand just because a man
is older does it make him older mentally
right
yeah see see what just happened you're
right
no i've met them you've seen every older
man you've met he
like he's merely you're right
oh my goodness this woman
no i'm not you're right you're right no
i'm literally asking you
you never met an older no no you're
right no no you're right
let's say again what i just showed you
is when we're going down the rabbit
holes you want to go down
it's statistically insignificant i'm
asking a question
and i just told you um okay ma'am um
this is interesting but at the net net
of it
if this is how this is what turns you on
is this is a
36 man i honestly expect 36 euro women
to have a better grasp of who they are
and what they want but it sounds like
you want a partner and you need
betas that's fine
um but controlling
domineering control freak women they
make good side chicks they're great for
sex
they're great to you know swing by and
knock it off but
it's all said and done high value
productive competitive successful men
you don't know what they want they're
going to go out and get a feminine
beautiful inspirational cooperatives and
this
woman they're not gonna they're not
going to do this
i'm not going to sit back and go back
and forth and argue and debate
because this is no there's no peace in
this
so the type of man that you're talking
about they want the the pregnant
barefoot stay-at-home submission yeah
yeah okay so audience basically
this is and this is she's jealous i
i know this type she can't get the alpha
or the guy that she wants
right so she is jealous of the women
that get that gets
get that so she's belittling them right
now that's what she's doing
remember last week when woman said so
they want pretty slaves
this is this just this is just the other
copy of that argument
you all think you're just oh i'm not
arguing i was just asking it okay but if
you
if you think but come on that's the
weight you asked
there's nothing wrong listen no but if
you think
that's the only way that comes barefoot
and pregnant
then that shows me a lot more about you
than what reality is
no because the way you were speaking
that's how it was coming off so i would
just no no
no man no no that's not how it was
coming out that's how you perceived it
that's why i was asking to clarify that
i would certainly know man
i'm very good at what i said i didn't
say one who's barefoot and pregnant
i said feminine beautiful inspirational
so submissive and cooperative
you better want to try to put her in the
kitchen barefoot and pregnant that's on
you
and see this doesn't i mean there's
nothing wrong with that yes
here's the sad part
what you're doing doesn't work
okay and you were 36.
[Music]
what do they say the definition of
insanity is doing
the same thing over and over again
expecting different results
[Music]
that's the no man's land thing because
between 36
and 60 is one continual slide to the
grave
please get out the comment section i'm
not there
[Music]
that's what control freaks do get out of
the comment section because we're having
a conversation
36 to 60 is one lie to the great
because no man of substance of value
of quality is going to marry a woman
like this at the best you will get some
50
50 beta male where you are paying
most of the bills because the median
income in this country
for black men is forty two thousand for
forty one thousand four
five hundred and for white guys is fifty
two thousand that's the median income
east to west coast doesn't matter
fully 50 of the men make that and the
men who make more than that
don't want controlling dominion they can
afford to get different
so what does it mean that means either
you'd have to compete to get the men who
make more
when they want something different
or you'd have to try to get your mind
around it
be willing to accept less and then hope
the guys who are less
are silly enough to realize that
they're not your first pick you're not
there that you
those guys aren't your first choice
this is why i feel so bad for modern
women because you earned too much you
waited too late and
you you were lied to and told to go out
and make a job and a career and also
other kind of stuff
and you're so far outside of your true
feminine
god-given nature to where it makes you
unfit for relationship with the kind of
men
you want okay
and i can't do anything about it so
that's why i say therapy but you don't
want to
but you're not in therapy with anybody
you're your own therapist
yeah that's good he's giving her
constructive criticism
so that's fine but while you're doing
that
i feel like therapy is for people who
are in denial
you're right
damn you don't think so you're right
you don't think so you're right damn
it's a salvage i mean that's my personal
opinion
you're right i feel like therapy is for
people who are in denial
and if you know what your flaws are
and you know what you need to work on
then you could be working on it right
show me a better outcome
damn i can do that
no you really can i can
i can do that
it's it'll be okay though oh i'm fine
i'm fine too i'm fabulous
okay i'm gonna just end it there she
would not be on the show if she was fine
and this is the lie
that women will say to put your career
first you don't need no man
but yeah 37
with that attitude good luck
but let me know in the comments if you
agree or disagree do not forget to like
and subscribe i'll talk to you guys
next time